we're in Chandler Arizona this morning
to check in on whammo and its commercial
ride service way mo1 it's been an
operation about six months now with
several hundred regular users of the
system hailing Pacifica hybrid minivans
outfitted with lidar as cameras radars
all sorts of gear the technology is
getting very good very very quickly
could it be ready for large-scale
deployment within two three to five
years probably so but a big issue that
goes hand-in-hand with the technology
itself is public acceptance do people
get along with these vehicles those are
some of the things that weigh Mo's
trying to figure out and has to answer
before it can really scale this up to
the multi-billion dollar business that
it envisions someday we're on a street
where the posted speed limit is 45 miles
an hour we're doing right around that
currently it's very smooth in terms of
acceleration this is a fairly easy
street that we're on right now traffic's
not terribly heavy we're not doing this
during rush hour for the rider what
we're seeing on the display is both our
vehicle but then everything that the
vehicle sensors are seeing but doing it
in kind of a subtle way way mo one is
using safety drivers all the time there
is also another part of the program
called the way moe early rider program
and in the case of the early rider
program some of those have no driver at
the wheel few years ago I started seeing
him driving around town and stuff inside
the first thing I did is look it up I
mean how can you miss one of these
things going around and they had a forum
online for sign up for the early writer
program and I actually was part of the
early writer program at that point
what's the
you know most surprising things ever
happened or weirdest there was a
consistent turn going to my house that
was interesting for the vehicle to
handle and it's something was something
that happened repeatedly a number of
times and kind of watching the cars
eventually figure it out and learn how
to deal with it that was pretty cool we
just dealt with a situation that deals
with that category of unpredictability
where we had a pedestrian waiting to
cross the street signaled for us to go
ahead the van began to go ahead but then
the pedestrian crossed anyway obviously
the vehicle stopped and waited for him
to cross but that's where you get maybe
these situations of fuzziness where even
properly interpreting what was going on
there was that unpredictable element
where a guy just crossed the street
anyway we've had collisions where the
victim vehicle was way more vehicle yeah
yet aware of any collision that's
occurred or the way the vehicle was at
fault obviously our concern here is
Public Safety and our mission as a
police department is to keep our city
safe
so as this technology was unfolding
naturally there are a lot of questions
lots of unknowns so we've been
relatively constant communication a
webmo has with us as as things had
progressed over the years beyond the
initial shock of not seeing a person and
vehicle which again we're getting used
to there are protocols have been
established and as a police officer that
was one of the first questions who gets
the ticket I didn't contact whomever and
we were able to work through those about
a year ago a little over a year ago with
the State Department of Public Safety
and so it's not just that Chandler
issues not just a regional issue we want
to make sure as a scales that the entire
state is in alignment you're not an
incredibly dense city so you know it's
not San Francisco it's not Chicago it's
a little more spread out what makes this
do you think a good place to test the
way moe
program because you know you've got the
good weather but my guess is most people
are driving themselves most places most
of the time well for way most point of
view
we're all that we are they wanted to
check out a server a suburb but we also
have some harsh summer conditions we get
these bizarre-looking Deathstorm
dust storms that look like something out
of a sci-fi movie but I also think we
are a city that again that has an estate
that has embraced technology that we've
been very laissez-faire with them in
terms of not putting on or not desiring
to put on a lot of regulations either as
a state or as a city so that they can
develop this technology and very
conservatively very cautiously the
technology could be ready today but if
people aren't comfortable with it if
other drivers aren't comfortable with it
it's not going to work and this is a
company that wants to have a very long
life thinking decades ahead and all of
these problems have to be solved figured
out answered with what they're doing
here in Chandler before they take it
elsewhere